is it about me that mentioned I want so
here honestly yeah like everything
starting with your face first just like
you're smelling something that doesn't
smell good you don't look like you have
bones under your body at all you're just
sort of like an old baby it's a complete
answer when was the last time you
engaged in intercourse do you mean like
a full-on kind of so you're absolutely
no it's more just like oh gosh this has
is it March already so tired of being
such a dork mm-hmm i beer wanna be a guy
that no matter where they are there's a
possibility you could have sex in a
bathroom I want to be sex in the
bathroom people that's so cool how do we
do this how was this done it would be
nice to meet some girls though I go on
dates all the time no you don't - come
on Lenny when was the last time you were
out on a date what day is today Sunday
1986 hey Do It Yourself put together are
you familiar with cooling the squeezing
it's like a glass of wine for the prize
let me do with your face you're not
blinking whatsoever no girls don't like
guys from upper-middle class
Pennsylvania what do they like they want
like bad boys have been in fights
what's up
I guess I kinda have a [ __ ] side my
people are weird down for years
what's wrong with the glass that's a
nasty white girl Kovach weirdo
you look really nice I'm not used to
seeing you with this much makeup is the
wine going to aggravate your IBS I don't
smoke
babe come on take a poll okay I see what
the future is all about them I'm good
thanks
I'm really glad that we're doing this
together you know I'm gonna get up on
the bar I'm putting this on the Internet
oh man that lady took our spot this is
part of our problem we're to passing hey
jump though you were so yelling here if
nobody theta-d bouzouki then the Xtreme
spotless